nation that's not fair you want to
criticize islam and the prophet muhammad
saw islam for islamic law and warfare
and governance fine but what's your
brilliant alternative look it's easy for
christians to criticize muhammad saw
islam for violence and intolerance
because the reality is setting up laws
and establishing governance is never a
peaceful process no matter how good and
pure a person you are there's always
evil people that are going to oppose and
fight you so what are you going to do
are you going to give up establishing
just laws on earth and allow evil
satanic forces to rule or are you going
to fight back which means resorting to
violence because those are the only two
options what's so bizarre from
christians is that they criticize the
prophet muhammad for this they criticize
him for violence but that violence is
inevitable for anyone who wants to
establish a just society in the vision
of god almighty
and the guy thinks he's his first
impression of his revelations was that
they were demonic he has to be talked
out of that by his wife and her cousin
uh he tried repeatedly
to commit suicide whenever something was
going wrong he would try to kill he
would try to hurl himself off a mountain
to delivering revelations promoting
polytheism
i mean where do you see that in the
prophet someone delivers a revelation
promotes polytheism comes back later and
says the devil made me do it
towards them
in matthew 5 jesus says
you have heard that it was said you
shall love your neighbor and hate your
enemy but i say to you love your enemies
and pray for those who persecute you so
that you may be sons of your father who
is in heaven we can see how this command
to love even our enemies
combined with the biblical teaching that
all human beings are created in the
image of god influenced early christian
thought in romans 12 the apostle paul
says if possible so far as it depends on
you be at peace with everyone if your
enemy is hungry feed him and if he is
thirsty give him a drink
in first corinthians 16 he says let all
that you do be done in love
in 1st thessalonians 3 he says may the
lord cause you to increase and abound in
love for one another and for all people
the author of hebrews in hebrews 12 says
pursue peace with all people in 1st
peter 2 the apostle peter tells us to
honor
all people
so whether you are christian
muslim
jew hindu buddhist atheist agnostic
young old white black
straight gay trans whatever you are
created in the image of god and
christians are commanded to love and
respect you based on our shared nature
and the love of god
that yes islam has violence and islam is
not tolerant of every belief in way of
life and that's a good thing as i'll
explain instead this is what we read in
the bible about moses in numbers 31
verse 14 to 18 of the bible we read and
moses was angry with the officers of the
army moses said to them have you let all
the women live now kill every male among
the little ones and kill every woman who
has known man by lying with him but all
the young girls who have not known man
by lying with him keep alive for
yourselves kill all the women and
children but keep the virgin girls for
yourselves as sex slaves that's what the
bible claims moses said so i want to ask
david wood do you think that moses was
an evil bloodthirsty man are you going
to denounce moses in this debate because
i don't want to
see how because i don't see how you can
denounce the prophet muhammad when you
have the example of moses getting angry
because his soldiers are not killing
enough women and children there's
nothing like that in the quran or hadith
or in the islamic tradition more broadly
the fact of the matter is when we look
at the context content of mosaic law in
the old testament it contains stoning it
contains expansionist war it contains
destroying the idols of pagan religions
it contains slavery it contains all the
things that christians criticize islam
for and it even goes beyond islam in
advocating killing women and children so
if islam muhammad and the quran are evil
because of these practices then mosaic
law moses and the old testament are at
least as evil
standard but the problem gets even worse
for christians this is because obviously
moses didn't just make up the law he was
only conveying the commandments of god
almighty you could just say well don't
you christians believe that god revealed
those things
in the past uh yes yes we do so if
stoning expansionist war and slavery are
evil then the god of the old testament
was evil or if slavery are evil then the
god of the old testament was evil
killing women children and infants
there's nothing like that in the quran
and hadith so isn't this the most
outrageous double standard david wood
please explain this explain how you can
criticize islam and smear the prophet
muhammad sallallahu islam as a violent
bloodthirsty war monger when according
to your own theology your god jesus
christ also commanded and approved of
all these things and more so david wood
you're extremely dishonest when you
criticize islam and in fact christians
should really hate you for what you're
doing because you're essentially
training your fellow christians to
reject the bible and hate moses and
jesus because when you tell
a personal messiah for individual
salvation
you could just say well don't you
christians believe that god revealed
those things
in the past uh yes yes we do and so did
your prophet
in fact according to your prophet daniel
allah revealed the torah
that you're
criticizing and calling uh saying that
it calls for genocide so uh you and your
followers are attacking
your own god and your own prophet here
interesting debate tactic uh mocking
your own god and profit is sure to catch
us off guard
[Applause]
kinds of acts of violence and
intolerance i'm not saying that
everything that's in the old testament
is exactly true because as muslims we
believe in tariff basically that the
older revelations have been modified and
distorted and corrupted and by the way
this is the view that is corroborated by
western scholarship but i'm not going to
affirm or deny these things that are
attributed to moses i'm just saying you
explain them you explain how you cannot
you consider muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam as an evil warmonger
bloodthirsty but moses you don't seem to
have the same position
where are these miracles too so they
knew who they were rebelling against if
they went after israel
by contrast the quran repeatedly denies
that muhammad's revelations
were accompanied by any miracle other
than the quran itself
well let me just respond to the miracles
point um there are entire books written
about the miracles of the prophet
muhammad
it's a whole genre
and and there are so many hundreds of
different miracles that were conducted
other than the quran yes the quran is
the main miracle of the prophet saw i
saw them if you want to call all of
those fabrications that came later
what's your evidence for this because
these are coming from hadith that even
western academics are sourcing to within
50 years
maximum maximum a hundred years of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi saldam's life
miracles that the canaanites and the
amalek witness where's your proof that
those aren't fabrications uh so i think
this is a kind of a weak argument um
uh
the exodus was accompanied by
constant miraculous intervention god is
reigning food from heaven
uh he is parting the red sea
and he's
literally going around as a pillar of
cloud by day and a pillar of fire by
night so here again
if there were a pillar of fire or a
pillar of cloud giving us orders right
now and you say i don't have to listen
to you
or if you're you're
you're not one of the people who were
actually following him you're someone
else and you're saying i don't care what
that pillar of fire says i don't care
about these people who are just led
through the the sea i say god has the
right to give life or to take life
you need to address the points that i'm
making you're it seems like the argument
that you're making is that moses had
miracles and therefore it's it was okay
to wipe out the canaanites and the
amalekites and the other tribes
but that how does that argument make
sense because the order in the old
testament is to kill babies as well and
children
uh do the babies understand miracles do
the children like are they responsible
for recognizing the truth of moses's
message again i'm not claiming that this
is actually what moses did this is what
what is attributed to him in the old
testament so i want you as a christian
who accepts the old testament and thinks
that moses was given commands by god who
by the way is jesus christ part of the
triune god explain how you are not
how you would not be forced to denounce
moses's policies and jesus's policies if
you're using those kinds of criticisms
against muhammad again